well uh
i have to apologize for being late
uh the reason i'm late is that i
completely forgot
uh no real excuses uh
last night here was valentine's day so
my wife and i went out for a very nice
dinner
and somehow in my mind i thought that
was friday it must be getting old
so
we were having a pleasant morning and uh
you know breakfast and i was uh
in fact i started doing some farsi
learning and uh persian as i want to
call it now
and
um i got a phone call saying where are
you
and of course i wasn't uh have my
steve's language workout so i apologize
to those of you who are there
i
no excuse
uh but except that i just got the days
confused and i've forgotten all about
the fact that monday wednesday and
friday i'm here for my language workouts
and what i i thought about because i
think ahead of these things of what i
want to talk about and i wanted to talk
about
you know using your online language
tutor
with reference to what i'm doing in
farsi
uh i have as you know i am an input
based learner i think that and that's i
mean link is designed around making
input based learning that is learning
from audio and text content learning
from listening and reading making it as
efficient as comfortable as easy to do
as effective as possible but the main
thrust of it is input
and i typically don't spend a lot of
time
uh talking certainly not in the initial
stages uh of course i look forward to
when i will have the opportunity to talk
a lot
but as i'm sort of climbing up the steep
cliff which is where i am in arabic and
persian right now
then my main activities are listening
and reading some reviewing of words
however i have started doing more
uh you know interacting with tutors
and a major no
sort of one of the limitations of
speaking with a tutor historically at
least in my perception has been
that the range of vocabulary that you
can cover
is limited
uh you're using the words that you can
use and you're struggling to understand
so that the sort of language density of
the sort of online online interaction
with the tutor at the early stages is
not very
high it's not very language intense as i
would call it whereas if i am listening
or reading i'm getting more and more
words
you know repeated exposure to words that
i've met before
meeting new words and so forth so i
spent most of my time listening and
reading in fact most of my time
listening
um
because i can do that in the car i can
do that while i'm working out in the gym
i can do it while i'm doing the dishes
and so forth then i go back to the
reading to get a sense of
you know to understand some of the areas
that i continue to have trouble
understanding however i am using the
tutor more and i want to show you how
this can be done
as a source of input
because when i speak to my tutors
i'm trying to say certain things and i
say them correctly or i don't say them
correctly or i can't remember the words
or it's a new word and the tutor
tells me the word and of course if she
tells me the word
and i only hear it i
it doesn't even register i i have no
sense of what that word is but then if i
get that in writing
then of course i have a better chance of
beginning to learn that word or that
phrase
and so
in selecting tutors at link
i select those tutors who give me a good
report
some tutors give you two three lines
some tutors give you none and i will
show you here uh when i go to share the
screen
the kinds of reports that i'm getting
from my farsi tutors i have two farsi
tutors
and
they come they're
fairly extensive like 10 15 20 lines
and of words and phrases that i tried to
use or that i didn't know the word for
and they provide a recording
so therefore
this then is imported as content i mean
that link once you get your tutor report
there's a button there click
it's imported
in the sort of conversation reports
course
in in link
and so you can go back to them over and
over again and when you do that
you uh remember those conversations that
you had so let me share the screen
and i'll show you how that works and how
that's i find that very effective
because
the words that come up
in your conversation first of all you
tend to have the same conversation you
know go over some of the same ground
uh you tend to make the same mistakes so
to some extent the same words come up
often but every time there's new words
introduced
and as i say you're sharing something
that's fairly high resonance because
it's things that you were trying to say
so let me show you that
all right so we'll go over here
start screen share
presumably now you're able to see my
lessons
at
that link
one thing i should show you
because i think it is kind of
interesting
is uh just to put and i should do this
with arabic as well
just to put um
my persian learning experience
uh into context so there's sort of the
activity over the last seven days
so because i'm going
you know persian arabic persian
so that the daily activity is you know
bunched up
three days on three days off
although there is an accumulation here
of known words or if i look at uh
you know listening activity
now there again it's
you know bunched up but it's constantly
accumulating but if i go to look at
all time i.e when i started
here again you can see that
you know i started
sometime around actually
maybe july started looking at farsi
started listening to it not very much
spent a certain amount of time with my
farseer persian
then in preparation for my trip to
morocco i left
it entirely and focused on arabic
then after leaving morocco it's
basically since leaving morocco that i
have put the greatest amount of effort
into
my uh persian learning
it's
you know any of these activities
listening reading
links created words red they're all
going to show the same
but it's useful i think to have the
statistic because often we forget when
did we start when did we spend time on
the language when did we stop studying
the language
now if i then go to my lessons
and in fact let's go to the here
and if i look at my conversation reports
i have had 19 conversations
in persian so this is another good thing
and you know
when we didn't have uh
farsi
or persian tutors at link i went to
italki
but even if you do it at italki
if they send me via skype or via email
a text of our discussion and their
recording of what was in the report then
i can import it into link
so
uh now this 19 number now let's let's
open this up open
so it's starting in august 20th now i
had some difficulty importing these so
this 3 august 20 is only this is the
same
discussion august 21st august 30th two
of those three of those came in i had a
problem i can't remember what it was
four of them those are all the same
and then we start into
september 6th 7th 19th
13th rana was my first tutor she's a
link tutor and then i also found another
tutor nazi
who
oh it's interesting too rana is married
to a pole and lives in poland la histan
as it's called in persian and nazi lives
in
iran in tehran
one of the things that's very important
i find with tutors
so let's talk a little bit about what
makes a good tutor
number one you have to have someone with
good skype connections or
google hangouts or whatever you're using
um when i was doing greek what was a bit
discouraging is that it seemed that
every tutor i found in greece had a
terrible skype connection
if the skype connection isn't good i i
tend to discontinue
uh surprisingly nazi in tehran has
excellent uh
connectability excellent uh sound and
picture and the same is true with rana
so
now let's give you an example
uh but but first of all i want to show
you that that
you have all of these that is a record
of and i go back to them and i review
them many many times and also i add them
to playlists so i have them on a
playlist so that i can listen to them
the most recent ones here
uh i haven't yet added but i can
that adds it at the playlist
at the playlist
okay
now uh let's have a look at one of what
one of these looks like so we open this
one here with uh nazi
um
let me just let it come open here
now the first thing is
that it comes with sound
and it's six
and a half minutes six and a half
minutes
of nazi recording
phrases words that i had difficulty with
and typically these are
i guess up to two types
one is going to be you know hello how
are you you know which we always start
with so there's a number of them we have
different ways of asking people you know
you know
and he knew what's new
no nothing new or and then i forgotten
nothing special so you learn different
ways of grieving
and then we'll get into
talking about
what we like to eat or
political situation in central asia or
any number of things so
very often these are going to be words
that are of interest to me and so and
very often they'll show up time and time
again because i keep on making the same
mistakes
but i find that that
input
created
through uh these uh conversations
is uh is is tremendously is is excellent
i'm interested in it i i remember trying
to use those words these are words that
i want to use
uh i'll go away and listen to it uh on
my playlist on my on my you know ipod
uh touch or on my iphone
uh still miss certain things go back
here review it again
you know i can
you know as i say
go from page to page and review
uh
you know
i know you see here again i look at it
right away out of context i don't know
what it is unfortunately texas speak
doesn't work
for
persian
[Music]
i've forgotten what that is
[Music]
[Music]
you know confuses me i must say i don't
know but it's my mind it's there i'll
eventually
get to it uh you'll see how much
difficulty i still have in reading
uh i saw a uh
a twitter or a tweet from someone saying
they've now learned the arab alphabet
and uh
here uh you know they never couldn't
make any sense out of this writing and
now they can't
in my experience it's a long road bad
monster
this is a phrase that's taking a little
bit out of context
or mod konam i really don't know what
that means
okay
learn okay yo
now yo
i know and so yeah yo
you learn he learns okay and at this
point i might just say you know what i
know that i've seen it i struggled with
it a bit but let's remove it because
it's so
uh
you know i have so many yellow words i
like to reduce them i can always go back
and save them again a lot fun
i hope that's when i know a lot fun
please
and here is
uh
vapor vapors feed
ba
pepsi i think means to be afraid but i'm
not 100 sure um
uh so all
uh
oh answer
before sad
man
[Music]
if you ask me something i'll give you
the answer something like that ask
all right
so i'm trying to show you that
uh
we try we often take stabs at words
we you know the whole process of
learning a word and especially in a
in a writing system that's different
we're anxious to try to come up with
something and if we get a large enough
context and if we're listening to it at
the same time we
kind of get it but then once it's taken
in isolation again it's it's much more
difficult
is words that one has no question i know
that one so here i might just go
bingo i know it
reached so
[Music]
so each
saw so each switch switch okay i get it
all right
switch flip card switch okay switch i
think i can go to three on that one
uh
this is
bushid boshi
you must okay
that's i'm pretty good at that one i'll
move it to a three
uh
depends a little bar me so here i would
say okay it's not carbohydrate i don't
think it's depends i don't think it's a
little so must be good
[Music]
let's see what happens
whoa all right i'm not quite sure what
tense this is how it fits in
uh
it says in the attached phrase that's
fine i'll work my way towards it i might
move it to a two here
because i kind of have got it
so here we go uh
geography all right geography
i think i might just give myself that
one
maybe that's a report in which case it
would be her here her or his report
we'll give that a try and not be wrong
uh what do you know but here
that actually at the end means it's his
or her report
so i might
just put that in there to help the next
person who comes along
um
next
um
seo
ceo
at any rate it's politics let's see what
the uh
so that's fine i'll move that to a three
because i'm not totally sure how that
one gets pronounced
i mean ruse's day so it's got to be
every day
uh
every day give that a two
we're nearing i mean i'll go through
this just to show you what i struggle
with when i do these
uh
means to come back
come back all right that one should be
good i give it to myself
okay i'm out of there but the point is
here's this text with a lot of words
that are important to me
i'll go over it many times
i can go back to ones i did months ago
i listened to it
and i look forward to my next session
and where i probably will make some of
the same mistakes again
but uh i just want to share with you how
i use my uh tutor reports as a form of
content
so
with that
again i apologize for being late this
morning
and uh let's now stop sharing
and stop
and uh i'd be very interested if there
are any questions
and i think we may already have some
okay so a couple of questions here
uh
how many hours a day should i spend with
listening
um
you know it's i have no set
uh
not amount of time
uh
i try to get in as much as i can
most of my listening is while i am doing
other things
so you know i clean up i actually make
breakfast so we might make some porridge
uh typically we start with some fruit
some porridge coffee toast we have
fairly big breakfast i make the
breakfast i clean up after breakfast all
of that is listening time
uh
i like to
once a day once every two days
do some exercise so i listen when i do
that
now i've started in the morning i spend
three four minutes doing different kinds
of planks and so i'll have the sound
going while i'm doing those
if i drive anywhere or if i go anywhere
on my bicycle i'll listen so typically i
will get in
half an hour to an hour a day
and whatever i listen to if i don't
understand it all i want to be able to
get to that text
and review it again
not in the hope that i'll nail
everything down but it's just this
gradual process of exposing
the brain to
comprehensible content comprehensible
input in listening and reading that
eventually
these things are going to settle in and
they do because there's no question that
i have a much better understanding of
persian now than i had when i started so
the proof is that you are acquiring more
and more of the language it doesn't
matter how much you forget you have to
always remind yourself of what you have
already achieved
but i would say that 45 minutes to an
hour a day it should be possible to
fit that amount of listening time into
your day that would be my advice
uh
here should i wait
uh until
5k words to speak like you did in check
or do you think i should start speaking
now because i'm excited
if you're excited start speaking
enthusiasm as i say you know whenever
you do something you want to do like if
you are curious about a point of grammar
and you look it up that's more likely to
stick than if a teacher kind of pushes
some grammar explanation at you if you
are motivated to speak you want to speak
uh what i did find if i i could say
without hesitation that if i had had the
many stories in check
i would have started speaking much
earlier
uh
you need to have some kind of basic
material with a lot of repetition where
you listen often and you're building up
some phrases and some basic and
particularly because the mini stories
focus on the most common verbs and you
need verbs you'll need i put take go
forget decided think plan all these
verbs you need them to have a
conversation so uh you have the many
stories in check if you're so inclined
at link
and if you're motivated you're excited
as you say i would definitely start
speaking earlier uh i i
with check i just didn't have enough
content that got me
got any momentum going and so even when
i started speaking after six months
which i thought was very early compared
to my experience with russian
i really really struggled
whereas in farsi and arabic i mean uh my
first session in august with um rana at
that time i was able to say some things
i probably and i there i'd been at
farsi for you know a few weeks so the
many stories with the repetitive
listening uh prepares you for speaking
early and i also think that compared to
when i was doing check link is better
than it was then
so the whole efficiency of that learning
environment makes it possible to start
speaking earlier but i definitely
would
make sure that the tutor has you know
good skype connections etc but also um
sends you a good report with the things
that you struggle to say
no english just the target language
and
an audio file a recording of three four
five six minutes of those notes
okay now how long can you hold the plank
well
uh i the longest i have held because we
we got out of this planking thing
watching a video on youtube and this gal
who was doing it she had us doing two
and she had us doing one minute one and
a half minutes two minutes two and a
half minutes so we went up to two and a
half minutes and then worked our way
back down again then someone said you
know you shouldn't overdo the planking
can be bad for your back so what i do
now is first thing in the morning
i do a two minute plank
then i do basically
45 seconds
on each side like side planks
and then i do another minute
uh sort of like climbers where i'm
this is now i'm planking you know a
push-up style not on my elbows
uh because the other plank is on the
elbows and here i lift my knee up to my
to my uh arm
so the answer is right now i i don't
know how long i can hold the plank for i
could probably go three minutes but i'll
just do two minutes
so
there you have it not related tell
everything but so if i do that in the
morning
uh that's four minutes
perhaps longer with the you know
time between the different planks
five minutes so there's five minutes if
i say you got to go 45 minutes there's
five minutes
of listening
i have tried
uh listening
uh excuse me a planking while reading
a text but it's a little difficult to be
planking and then you come across a word
you don't know and you would really like
to kind of
put your cursor on that word or your
your stylus to see what it means and so
in the end i stopped doing that so i
just listened
uh okay
there we have it are there any other
questions
okay
all right i think that's it
again i apologize for being late i just
simply forgot that today was for for
whatever reason i thought today was
saturday
and these things happen
maybe it's my age
okay thank you for listening i look
forward to your comments
and i do
like to answer any comments i get on
youtube for those of you who
see this video later
that i do try to answer and i appreciate
any comments or questions that and in
any language i had the other day some
questions in check and in japanese so
please let me know and uh we'll look
forward to the next one i promised well
i promise i shouldn't promise but i'll
try to be there
as scheduled on monday bye for now
you